being honest
is what counts trying to make the
ordinary extraordinary
is so much better than starting with the
extraordinary
i think a joke has to stand up when it's
comedic value not on whether the person
agrees with it
or not right do you know what i'm saying
absolutely you know we talk about
things all the time and we haven't got a
side right we're just discussing them
and that's what a joke is often a joke
is at its best discussing something not
coming down
on one side or the other because that's
rallying an offense is good
offense makes people think it makes them
think
it makes them come up with another
argument if i had made
my own little demo of it because if you
think about it it doesn't jump off the
page you know
um middle-aged man says a joke that no
one laughs at looks at the camera
touches tie
it it's i think
i think comedy is you know
to be performed
i'll tell my process right
okay this is it probably the biggest
single influence
um on my creative process was something
my old english teacher said to me when i
was about 13 or
14. he just said write about what you
know i usually wrote about things that i
saw on telly you know when we ever had
to write a story
it was about a maverick cop
or you know a cowboy i always thought my
stories were the best they were more
exciting
and whenever i wrote a story and handed
it in i always got it back
to melodramatic write about what you
know and this was frustrating because i
was thinking
it's either good or it isn't you know
and i thought my stories were so
who who wouldn't like a story called
jezek
about a maverick cop who didn't play by
the rules
what he mad this could be on telly
in fact i'm sure it was and all the
other kids were getting bees and a's
writing about what they did
and then one day i just got fed up so i
thought i'd teach him a lesson
and i tried to do the most boring story
in the world
my mom used to go around a neighbour's
house she was an
elderly lady in a in her 80s and my mum
would go around
you know every day and clean up do a bit
of shopping and cook her a meal
and sometimes i'd go around there and
sort of watch
because i was bored and it's that it's
not an exciting thing
for a 13 year old boy to watch his mum
clean up after an old lady
that isn't my idea of fun so i thought
i'll write a story about that that is so
boring
and i wrote in every detail i i i
thought i was being really clever
going um we went around we came in there
was a there was a smell of tea
and lavender and mold and
my mum first started to clean the floor
the old lady said
have you eaten the old lady said i
haven't eaten today no and i did it all
when i thought i was being so funny and
uh getting my own back on this teacher
and i handed it in
and i thought that'll show him and you
know the next day
he'd mark them all when he was looking
on the hands now and he got mine
and he just threw it at me like that
and i opened it up hey and i looked at
him and he just went
and it was the proudest moment of my
life
it sort of taught me that being
honest is what counts
trying to make the ordinary
extraordinary is so much better than
starting with the extraordinary
because it doesn't really connect you
watch those short shows and it washes
over you don't think about it the next
day
whereas if something is real for one
person it's touched their life
you know and i think as a creator and a
director
it's your job to make an audience
as excited and fascinated about a
subject as you are
and and real life does that this this
reputation of beings like
me a shock comedian or being cruel right
i i i don't i've never seen it
i've never seen that in myself i think
it's
you know because you deal in taboo
subjects and um
and the golden globes you know but i
mean
i was teasing some millionaires yeah
that wasn't a room full of wounded
soldiers
i mean and it's like
yeah and
and i'm and i'm one of them but i was
playing an outsider because it's
nauseating to go out there and go all
right brad hey george thanks for letting
me use your villa it's horrible
yeah you know people at home aren't
winning awards so you
you you it was a i tried to make it more
of a spectator sport right but
i i i don't i i don't there is any
cruelty
in my comedy or drama or anything i i um
my favorite show growing up was the
waltons right do you know what i mean
right um
even in my up i deal with taboo subjects
and i talk about this in this new one of
humanity
but i try and explain a joke about a bad
thing
isn't necessarily a bad thing it's not
the same as the bad thing
it's not a bad thing to joke about it it
depends what the joke is
it doesn't have to be pro or anti the
bad thing it could just be
you know we talk about things all the
time and we haven't got a side
right we're just discussing them and
that's what a joke is often a joke is
it's best discussing something not
coming down on on one side or the other
because
that's rallying i try and keep politics
and you know
i think a joke has to stand up when it's
comedic value not on whether the person
agrees with it
or not right do you know what i'm saying
absolutely but don't you think sometimes
you bring something out when we're
discussing
um things like oh what do what the
audience expect or what do they want
don't there's someone in me that says i
don't care it's not up to them
it's not up to them i'll do exactly what
i want and that you know
then you kind of if you if you didn't
like it i i i don't care
don't come and see me again don't ever
come and see me i think as long as
you're
i just don't want to be judged i really
don't want to be judged what i mean
is i don't i don't change anything that
i wouldn't want to do or has ever done
to find an audience i do what i do and
somewhere in the world
there's enough people that want to come
and fill that venue i suppose it's
because people think
um whatever they see of you that that is
you like
you know with stand up particularly my
my early
my first four stand-ups um it was a
persona i was playing sort of like a
a pub who said the wrong thing got
things wrong
right you know that um uh you know
almost
not quite archie bunker but you know
that sort of sure you know there was a
veil of irony too yeah
and it's great now because people get it
and so i'm still doing those things but
the audience knows that i'm not like
that just like you do with friends just
like you say awful things with friends
and you're
and they know you're not like that right
and um so that's that's nice
for them to people to know your real
self and you can
you can almost go further in your comedy
you know and
it's funny because you know uh with
everything that happened in the last
couple of years
when i started warming this show up i
was worried
about playing that persona because there
are too many people
that would agree with the wrong reasons
right do you know what i mean you don't
you don't want the wrong round of
applause right doing irony
right you know um
you're not afraid of dividing opinion
you're not afraid of you know some
people saying i disagree with you
there's a big difference between
um comedy and and uh and sense of humor
and i think that
um a comedian's job isn't just to make
people laugh that that's easy that can
be a reflex i mean
you see some comedians that it's the
rhythm they can even throw in a fake
punchline they'd get a laugh
um i think it's about making people
think about it and why it's funny and
and i think comedy is about empathy i
think you know
i can't laugh people i don't like i
think you should never be above the
audience
there's nothing remotely funny about
seeing
unfeasibly handsome brilliant people
come out and tell you why they're
brilliant
i want to see a putts losing his way
falling over
and getting back up and dusting himself
off and um
and you've always got to see that that
humanity that sort of
struggle in anything really
um as opposed to changing my personality
no i don't but of course um everything
you do has got
got a persona chat shows
i'm playing a sort of character it's not
completely me you know i never let my
guard down i don't act
when i'm on letterman or john stewart i
don't act completely like i do with my
friends you know you still edit yourself
you still
you still present um stand up
as again it's a this episode i play a um
a brasher more arrogant
more confident version of myself
and and then there's another level on
that that i usually play
the guy who says the wrong thing you
know the target of my
my stand up seem um like they're soft
targets but of course the target is
the audience's own prejudice and
middle class angst and me i mean i'm
always the butt of the joke
i'm i'm i'm ignorant i come down on the
wrong side
um i'm a joker nelson mandela
what a great guy often gets a round of
applause i go incarcerated for over 25
years
released in 1990 he's been out now for
19 years
and he hasn't reoffended i think he's
going straight
which shows you prison does work so i
always i play getting it wrong
you know um and then um
in the characters i play you know from
from
david brent to um andy millman
uh dr pincus in ghost town
they're they're variations of each other
i always play that
that that that putts that that
wisecracker in the face of adversity
um and um i i don't apologize for that
all i want to do now um
it's been more and more uncompromised
you know
uh i want to be as brave as i can
and i want to be as honest as i can
that's my only aim now
um obviously i want to make um people
laugh and
be interesting and do all the things
that are that are structurally important
and
act well all those things that are
practical things
but my motivation is to explore
um subjects that you know
need exploring um and and being
as honest and as brave as i can and
people can take it
this this notion that we as artists or
broadcasters or
we say oh is that a bit can the general
public take that i want to go would you
make that they're going through real
life
real life is much much worse and you
think that your show
will offend someone so what it isn't for
the people who are offended it's the
people who are not offended will get
something out of it and think for
themselves
and that aren't cowed and aren't worried
about th
this this thing this this ridiculous
notion that there are things you
shouldn't discuss
and i discussed taboo subjects because i
want to take the audience to a place it
hasn't been before
um and so
i think the more you get into something
the deeper you go the more interesting
it is i think it's when you skirt around
and
and and purposely make things
anodyne uh to please everyone you end up
pleasing no one
yeah i don't see the point i just seen
right might take half a day to film it
so if i write a scene and that takes me
five minutes
i count that as a day's work great so
i did that yeah yeah then i've got the
rest of the day for me to think
i'm joking aside um i have honed my um
creative process down to lots and lots
of relaxation and thinking
opening your brain and letting ideas
come
sitting in front of a uh a laptop eight
hours a day
is not productive you've got you've
gotta live you've gotta
go for runs you've gotta sit around
doing nothing you've gotta watch tv
you've gotta chat you've gotta do lots
and lots of normal things um
and and you know and a creative process
should
it shouldn't be happening it shouldn't
be worried about
structure and and this
this pandemic has been good for that
because there are literally more hours
in the day
for you uh that uh you know because i do
everything myself
half my day is add me yeah and when you
haven't got that
when you haven't got to do stuff because
you can't um
creativity it it flows
nothing gives me an adrenaline rush like
coming up with an idea
honestly i i i i can't sleep and if i
think of it before i go to bed
i've got a worker over so i don't forget
it when i i wake up and that's a that's
a lovely thing to wake up to
oh that idea right you know and it
doesn't get any better than when it's in
your
head really it and then you just gotta
ruin it as little as possible
honestly when i when i first started
this i thought i was a writer right
um and i probably only uh directed
because i
realized that i could protect the
writing and then i produced to protect
the
directing right right so it's all to
protect the idea
you